bonsoir alexis alors gilbert collard et
d'autres cadres du et rennes avant lui
rejoint donc la campagne d'eric zemmour
est une catastrophe pour le camp le pen
comme le dit d'ailleurs robert ménard
je ne sais pas si c'est une catastrophe
mais c'est de mauvais augure clairement
en pleine campagne avoir autant de
défections de cadres importants gilbert
collard c'est une personnalité
médiatique du rassemblement national
jérôme rivière qui était député européen
est à le patron de la délégation des
députés européens du rn damien rieu
également qui a été une cheville
ouvrière de dudu et rennes pendant des
années qui rejoint eric zemmour ça fait
beaucoup en quelques jours ce sont sans
doute les premiers mais pas les derniers
à rejoindre le polémiste qui fait
campagne je crois qu'il ya une fatigue
comme le disait eric zemmour de voir
leur assemblée nationale perdre dans ces
élections faire campagne mais ne jamais
briser ce plafond de verre parce que il
y a le poids de l'héritage le pen
évidemment marine le pen elle à cenon
est là cette famille elle essaye d'en
jouer mais c'est compliqué pour elles et
donc on peut voir qu'il ya une dynamique
du côté de la campagne d'eric zemmour
dynamique qui s'essouffle lecerf puisque
maintenant on rentre dans une course de
marathon mais du côté de marine le pen
une campagne où elle essaye de se
recentrer où elle essaye d'être
respectable elle ne fait plus peur elle
essaye d'être la candidate de droite
mais est ce que ça peut fonctionner
compte tenu de son passé de l'histoire
du rassemblement national
le risque c'est que derrière ces
défections de personnalités publiques et
bien les électeurs fasse le même chemin
du rassemblement national reconquête et
c'est justement ce point le pari de la
refondation et de l'union des droites
d'eric zemmour pas ce qui peut être
gagnant dans ce cas de figure quel que
soit le résultat d'avril 2022 d'ailleurs
au premier tour
alors clairement eric zemmour réussit là
un tour de force il était simplement
polémiste auteurs le voilà candidat avec
un projet celui de faire une nouvelle
droite une refondation avec reconquête
l'union des droites comme il le dit de
rassembler les électeurs des
républicains déçus par leur parti sans
doute trop européiste sans doute trop
macro nist et les acteur du
rassemblement national fatigué des
défaites fatigue et aussi de marine le
pen et de son inconstance sans doute et
là on voit qu'il réussit puisque
guillaume pelletier numéro deux des
républicains le rejoint qu'en sera-t-il
d'eric ciotti dans cette campagne il a
fait allégeance pour le moment à valérie
pécresse et suis bien sûr les
républicains dans cette union qui est
affichée mais on est encore loin de
d'avril donc reste à voir comment tout
ça va se passer et donc on voit bien que
il y a là un pari en train d'être
réussie déjà dans un premier temps de
rassembler deux camps en 1 re conquête
et derrière peut-être de faire un parti
pérenne au delà bien sûr du résultat
eric zemmour ne sera peut-être pas au
second tour peut-être sera-t-il à un
score calamiteux premier tour on est
encore loin du premier tour en tout cas
on voit qu'il y a une dynamique une
envie des militants qui viennent jeunes
moins jeunes des gens qui se
reconnaissent aussi dans les paroles
cash on va dire d'eric zemmour qui sont
les mêmes qu'il avait lorsqu'il était
polémiste mais il est maintenant
candidat et donc ils déroulent et pour
le moment on voit qu'il attire est ce
que ça peut durer est ce que autour de
lui peut se construire un parti ça c'est
une autre question on le verra
évidemment après les élections
présidentielles
un rôle que pourrait clairement joué
marion maréchal-le pen dans cette
affaire a tout à fait c'est la personne
de dot on ne parle pas beaucoup en ce
moment et qui pourtant regarde avec
attention ce qui se passe du côté de
reconquête parce que cette idée de
l'union des droites c'est elle qui l'a
eue que lorsqu'elle invite eric zemmour
à ce grand rassemblement de la droite et
il est là il vole un peu la vedette à
marion maréchal à l'époque avec un
discours qui lui a valu d'ailleurs
quelques soucis judiciaires et voilà
qu'après eric zemmour fait le même plan
finalement de dérouler cette union de la
droite cette union des droites qui était
le plan de marion maréchal donc est ce
qu elle reste discrète à dessin c'est à
dire en laissant eric zemmour faire ce
premier round cette première campagne
présidentielle sachant qu'il a très peu
de chance finalement d'arriver à être
élu ou même d'arriver au second tour et
donc à partir de là peut-être
entrera-t-elle dans le jeu politique
pour récupérer un mandat d'élu au
parlement bien sûr à l'assemblée
nationale aux législatives et ensuite
construire ce parti avec eric zemmour
mais aussi avec d'autres figures
peut-être qu'ils viendront des
républicains à l'issue du scrutin et et
dur assemblée nationale en ayant enfin
liquider l'héritage de la famille le pen
puisque est la même laisser tomber son
nom le pen elle s'appelle maintenant
marion maréchal et puis quelle heure a
laissé tomber le rassemblement national
issu du front national pour faire re
conquête c'est à dire tout un habit
nouveau pour un parti nouveau une sorte
de tea party à la française un parti
très adroite pour refonder une droite
des valeurs comme l'appelle eric zemmour
en revanche alexis à gauche la
refondation ce n'est pas pour tout de
suite françois hollande serait même en
train de réfléchir à prendre la parole
mais à votre avis pour me dire quoi
oui alors à gauche le changement c'est
pas maintenant la refondation non plus
françois hollande je ne sais pas alors
on a quand même la parti socialiste qui
ne veut pas mourir c'est beau à voir ils
luttent pour ne pas disparaître de la
scène politique nationale mais on voit
bien que c'est compliqué la campagne
d'ali des algos souffre d'un manque de
dynamisme terrible y compris en temps
réel dans les meetings et dans les
sondages des candidats de gauche du
parti socialiste à foison ne sait plus
quoi en faire alors arnaud montebourg
finalement se retire mais voilà
christiane taubira qui entrent en lice
avec la primaire populaire et et
pourquoi pas et pourquoi pas françois
hollande ancien président qui se dit et
si j'avais un truc à dire aux français
mais quoi s'imagine-t-il qu'après ne pas
avoir pu défendre son bilan en 2017 il
pourrait venir et essayer de se
présenter en président de gauche sauveur
de la gauche je ne sais pas je crois
qu'il ya un déni au parti socialiste de
voir finalement le rejet massif d'une
partie de la population par rapport aux
politiques qui ont été celles de
françois hollande à la trahison de la
parole donnée mon ennemi c'est la
finance et puis là résultat c'est la loi
de travail emmanuel macron donc on voit
bien que pour le parti socialiste ce
sera très compliqué il va falloir faire
le même travail je pense que eric
zemmour a fait à droite avec reconquête
changer de nom changeait aussi deux
parties liquider l'héritage finalement
de françois hollande parce que cet
héritage là ils plombent la campagne
d'abidal go et il plombe le parti
socialiste pour longtemps donc peu
importe ce cas nous dira françois
hollande je crois que ce sera encore une
microscopique prise de parole qui n'aura
aucun intérêt dans le cadre de cette
campagne présidentielle
l'exil poulain merci d'avoir été avec
tous nous avoir apporté votre décryptage